Шановні колеги європейська Солідарність
вітає позбавлення депутатів зрадників
депутатських мандатів але це дуже
половинчате рішення У нас сьогодні є
депутати які оголошені в міжнародний
розшук які ледь не призвели до
Міжнародного скандалу підриваючи довіру
з президентом байденим і сполученими
штатами Америки є обміняні депутати чому
їх не позбавляють мандатів сьогодні В
цій залі є депутати мабуть які мають
подвійне громадянство де Служба безпеки
України яка має дати повну інформацію
про таких депутатів щоби їх позбули
мандатів є нарешті рішення Ради
нацбезпеки і оборони щодо заборонених
партій це партія ширія це опзж чому
депутати цих партій включаються в
марафони і ведуть нормальне політичне
життя створюючи нові політичні групи і
фракції є нарешті був вірніше такий
депутат зрадник відправлять чи партії
Ковальов якого доблесні партизани
відправили на концерт Кобзона але він і
досі рахується депутатам Верховної Ради
і досі його картка для голосування є в
залі наша фракція вимагає системного
вирішення цього питання ми зареєстрували
законопроект про позбавлення
депутатських повноважень всіх депутатів
від заборонених фракцій ми зареєстрували
альтернативний законопроект щодо
заборони створювати їм як у парламенті
так і в е-е регіональних наших місцевих
радах депутатські нові групи і впливати
на прийняття рішень бути донорами для
партії влади по правильним голосуванням
ми вважаємо що депутати від заборонених
партій не можуть очолювати комітети а
внаслідок ключовий Комітет з питань
свободи слова очолює депутат від
забороненої партії тому Насправді це
дуже половинчати рішення і ми вимагаємо
винести на порядок денний наше
законопроекти які приводять в порядок
люстрацію люстрація і справедливість -
це те чого ви починає сьогодні
українська суспільство всі хто звали
російського окупанта на нашу землю мають
понести політичну відповідальність